ma combinaison squelette supplémentaire parce que je suis
paralysé de la taille aux pieds me permet
de marcher jusqu'à quatre milles
en une seule fois avec la batterie même si
hier j'ai réussi à marcher 5,4 milles
donc c'était
encore plus loin
alors quand j'étais à l'hôpital comme huit
il y a des années et je t'ai dit que je ne
marcherais plus
jamais je n'aurais jamais pensé dans un million d'années que
je pourrais faire des pas et marcher à nouveau
grâce à cette technologie incroyable je suis un
chanteur donc je peux chanter debout
je modèle donc je reçois  pour marcher sur les podiums,
vous savez que je peux me promener avec mes
enfants dans les bois à
travers le sable sur une plage des choses que
vous ne pouvez pas faire dans votre fauteuil roulant